Think about this. Everything you see, hear, feel, taste, and touch all happen
because of our nervous system. So every day, millions of sensory stimuli enter
our brains. Our brains interpret those and allow us to engage in our behaviors
and be successful. Every minute, thousands and thousands of neurons are firing,
and it makes our behaviour seem fluid and effortless, when in fact it's
actually quite complicated. Let's take a look at an everyday example that shows
how our nervous system allows us to be successful human beings. Something
amazing is about to happen. Lauren is about to see and then touch a dog, you
may think amazing, how boring and everyday. But in fact, it really is an
amazing process. Let's take a look at it a little more carefully. First, Lauren
sees Sputnik. The light waves enter her eye, stimulate sensory neurons in the
retina, which then send neuro impulses to the back of the brain. The visual
cortex in the occipital lobe lobes or the information get interpreted and made
sense of Sputnik. Next, Lauren decides to be friendly with Sputnik and reaches
down to pet him. For that to happen, something else needs to happen in Lauren's
brain. It has to send a signal to the motor cortex involved in moving her hand
to reach down and touch Sputnik. This impulse gets transmitted from the motor
cortex in the frontal lobe to the arm via inter-neurons in the spinal cord, and
motor neurons in the arm. Which contract muscles in the arm and move it back
and forth. When she actually touches Sputnik, sensory neurons in her fingertips
send neural signals back to her brain's sensory cortex. Here she has the
conscious sensation of furriness. At each step in this process, hundreds of
thousands of interconnected neurons are firing up to 200 times per second. This
whole process, from when Lauren first sees Sputnik to petting him, lasts all of
a few seconds. But look at what took place in these two to three seconds, that
allow for all of this to happen. Now, perhaps you can see why we call this
every day event, amazing.